we're here with the official Aquaman
character breakdown for injustice to now
this was taken from nether realms live
stream but considering the game comes
out this Tuesday May 16th go ahead and
hit that subscribe button to keep up
with all of our injustice to coverage
okay there's a lot of characters that a
defensive characters that are really
good from full screen right he is very
very good from this range because it was
tried it he out ranges almost every
character in the game and his moves are
very fast and they do a lot of damage
yep so from full screen he has his
tentacle strike which kind of replaces
is from the deep in the original game
and this was a great move this this this
really ups the ante on it though this
looks great tentacle yeah I absolutely
love it I love doing the boo-boo-boo-boo
the octopus is underground replays like
oh there's camera on that place
okay back back to the game
so the nice thing about this movie is it
tracks the opponent anywhere and a lot
of moves have like a closed minimum far
it's automatic it's it's you're telling
the octopus and the octopus knows where
to go this is intelligent I would say a
level 10 and the left octopus and when
you meet her burn it get another one so
it's a lot of damage
I'm missing it but well what about what
it's so funny we talk a lot tired man we
talk a lot about how you are we make the
joke a bit you being washed up yes and
now we're playing Aquaman and you are
you're washed on beyond just in eleven
miles down the ocean
he cannot hit from the deep and from the
beat yeah this be the first time I could
train my sister of this come on Steve
yeah back three this is another remove
his for two three in the original he
still has it
but he would throw the opponent the
opposite way now you can injure combos
for big damage and actually keep them in
front of you so you can choose or put to
put them in the corner and conform in
the clip in the corner keep them in the
corner you can throw them in screen if
you want if you don't even want to deal
with them right
um his other moves are back he's trying
to toss is it's not the greatest
projectile but it gets the job done
is scoop now one interesting thing is
normally it just knocks you down and he
gets a little damage if you have to
meter burn it and then you get a combo
look at that it was only two tries look
at that across the board in the game for
the most part special moves don't combo
unless you meter burns so he's no longer
an exception all of his big normals are
bad cuz back one two is for one the
second hit still an overhead is two to
three it's an overhead and then
obviously the big returning move is
trying to push this is kind of what the
character is built on and the thing is
you meet over it and that's a lot of
damage and you also see it does a ton of
block damage
now you notice in the original game one
of the reason that moves was so powerful
is he built meet her back every time it
was blocked in this one meter burn moves
do not build meet her on block so he can
do it and he can do a lot of chip damage
which is what he's meant to do but he's
not building meet her back to just keep
looping it over and over again so that's
what made him really strong an injustice
one right not only could he you know get
good block damage but here I'm also
getting meet her back at the same times
it so he can out range you and he could
do all this chip damage and he could
just keep looping it so we wanted to
keep that design because it's very fun
for Aquaman players a very defensive
player he was one of the defensive
players favorite characters so we wanted
to keep that he still does a lot of chip
he's still on range everyone he's
splitting the anti everyone but it's
just a little more fair because he can't
just loop it he has to think more about
how he's going to use a super meter we
give me a give me control here cool so
let's also talk about its character
power which is back uh its water of life
and this actually allows him to block
attacks that you don't know which one my
going on
you should be first-name lastname god
I've gotta go so if I turn it on and you
do for example three two that didn't
work
oh it's cuz I'm getting knocked over
here do one one to your she's able to
block now normally it's a combo do one
one two so falcomon has this on you can
actually take the hits and then get out
of a combo now this is an extremely
powerful character power it was arguably
the most powerful in the game the last
one and it's still really really great
but it doesn't last quite as long so
again we wanted them to play very
similar but just be a little bit more
fair for the other players so he could
still use it to get on the combos does
he now show that again how long less the
recharge on him so he doesn't last super
long that's the last super long it has a
pretty yeah the recharge is pretty low
pretty substantial yep the same
strategies that you would use like maybe
you get knocked down and you
preemptively do it in case they block
your wakeup attack or you can actually
see that you get combo those things
drives you still apply but because the
cooldown so long you're gonna have to
think about it more right can he block
for Gentiles if he has he can always
block projectiles I mean kit doesn't
even move the OH water shield is back
and you're still able to cancel it and
this will this will absorb any
projectile and you can meet her in it
and explode
still a great wakeup attack still the
ultimate clown closer and got one hit
left that he puts the song dub at me bro
donesies yeah people say donesies right
no they don't okay actually don't think
I thought they did that's on me okay so
essentially aqua he's pretty basic you
if you liked it in the original you're
probably stuck in a line come he plays
relatively similar he's still really
good character awesome new bro oh that's
amazing
so why don't we talk about some
invisibility let's do it alright so the
first one I gave them ooh I really like
the pants and I really like the trynna
the first one I gave him is the call of
ocean master ocean master as you know is
his evil half-brother Lorca now this
move is a buff it's a brand new move and
this increases the chip damage on all of
the tall's attacks so let's check this
out can you block generally not let's go
the corner alright let's go to the
corner and hold down all you have to do
is hold down your that toilet gotcha
alright so this is the chip damage
mobile you right that's pretty
substantial right right now look at this
fat boy alright let's start over
oh this is going to be outrageous you
ready me it has a lot of chip damage so
you put this on and he's even better
than he wasn't in just this one with
this chip and that made me so mad I hit
you with a toilet yeah that's uh the
toilet doesn't really hurt Aquaman
though because it's full of water and
Aquaman just absorbs it and gets
stronger it's also full of ceramic it's
step up so this buff is extremely
powerful if you're a player who just
likes to hold back it just do try it
down one try too much that that's your
game that's how you get the top eight at
tournaments you turn this on and you're
the ultimate version of that a chip
damage Aquaman right so the second movie
I gave them is actually really
interesting it is an offensive move it
is a power of Neptune
he puts this trident on the ground and
then a few seconds later it will explode
and you can do a closed version and you
can do this far version and it actually
has a blast radius you can see
and he has a meter conversion which will
do additional damage and not the mother
so this is a where maybe you're a player
and you'd like to keep your distance
you'd like to do from the deep check in
with this you can then use this and you
have offense from fullscreen oh so what
I'm really radically change this place
not let's kind of you can use it on the
setup it's really good check
yeah much a pretty interesting move
Rahman who's traditionally kind of a
basic character that just keeps people
away you can actually use this offensive
awesome so one more load out let's play
me against F player to blood for all
right this isn't a special bottle before
no I just let it for all right let's
take a look though huh
oh my it's grid its grid grid all right
so this loadout I used and I gave him
enhanced amitabh removes so let me show
you in the original game he did not have
with me to bring try to toss with this
ability could be to Burnett and it's
faster and dusky whoa load of damage and
then secondly I gave him a new meter
burn water shield that actually go oh
it's always like to think oh it's so
cool I haven't seen this one yet
you did this though you put these
together doesn't see this that yeah so
it goes from just like a cheap way to
win rounds to an actual projectile
Cup it yeah you can jump it if you're
ready but it's gonna be hard ready yeah
oh hey cool you hope you want to see the
super to your right alright
and this actually travels full sturdy
it's a very good super
[Music]
all that green coming out grid to grid
is super cool
that's a fun surprise for everybody
right yeah it's very red as well so
there that is how do you get you link
the console games the mobile game export
mobile games and console game and
there's well-liked type you want to find
out with those rewards work work go back
to watch watch our lost last year about
mobile